-Today is Friday.
Happy Friday, everyone.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Friday is when I usually
catch up on some personal stuff,
I got to be honest.
You know,
I check my inbox,
only on Fridays...
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-...and return some emails
and, of course, I send out
thank-you notes every week.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I was running a bit
behind today, so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow.
Very nice of them.
-James, can you give me
some thank-you note writing
music, please?
-[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
It's got a good jam to it.
-Yeah. Mm.
♪♪
-Thank you, Blue Origin
space flight team,
for looking like you took
your official photo
at a Sears Portrait Studio.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, residents of the town
in "Halloween" movies,
for continuing to live there,
even though there's been
a festive slasher on the loose
for 40 years.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
How bad could it --
-Yeah.
-This could be the year
he doesn't?
-"This house only costs
$10,000."
[ Laughter ]
-"They'll give us $10,000?"
-Yeah, to live there.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, people who leave out
a bowl of candy on Halloween,
for basically saying, "I'm sure
you look funny or scary,
or whatever. Just take a Twix
and get off my property."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm over it.
I'm over it."
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, patio heaters,
for coming in two styles --
street lamp
and Indiana Jones Temple.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I feel like I'm on vacation.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know they were Irish.
Paddy O'Heaters.
[patio heaters]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Who are you thanking now?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-Who are you thanking now?
-I write out thank-you notes.
I put them in the envelope
and they get sent to the...
-The people who you thank.
-...the proper -- yeah.
-People, yeah.
-Correct.
Or things or --
-Or whole towns.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so, this one, I think,
you'll really enjoy.
-I'm waiting for it.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you will.
♪♪
Thank you, Saran Wrap,
for always being
one small tug away
from being completely useless.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Is this the last one?
-No.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Mellowcreme Pumpkins,
for being candy corn that went
into Witness Protection Program.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a goodie.
-Mmm, candy corn.
-Yep.
Here we go.
♪♪
Thank you, haystacks,
for letting people decorate
their house with horse food.
There you have it, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Those are thank-you notes!